look times have changed when it comes
down to buying cars I understand into
80s 90s maybe even the 2000s people
would go to the dealership getting
themselves mentally ready to face off
against this car sales guy and then you
have to Teo to the manager and then you
have to see what finance department for
two hours and say no no no finally six
hours later ten pounds later you walk
out with a car you're absolutely
frustrated you go home fighting your
wife your mom your dad or your
girlfriend today it's a complete
different time so I'm gonna share with
you how I've been buying cars for the
last seven years look just in the last
seven years about somewhere around two
and a half million dollars worth of cars
and I can tell you from experience I've
made all the mistakes and the worst
thing about buying the cars of
frustration that comes after you go into
a dealership and the reason why I say
that is because typically when people
buy a car the mistake they make is they
go to a dealership first and that's not
what you want to do first here's what I
recommend
the first thing you ought to do is call
an online auto broker here's why they
have inventory of every single car in
America let me explain I wanted to buy a
dawn I was looking for Salamanca blue
dawn that's the only one I was
interested in I called him
Danny Danny looked up in his inventory
came back and told me there's one in
Naples Florida for sale right now I said
great I call Naples dealership myself
they told me four hundred and six
thousand dollars he calls the dealership
he got three hundred and eighty eight
thousand dollars three days later that
car was delivered to my house I never
had to talk to the sales guys to
negotiate nothing he did it for me car
came to me delivered I sign a piece of
paper 30 second boom the guy was gone
right so number one they have inventory
number two time I don't have to sit on a
dealership for hours and say oh my gosh
I went to the first one then the second
one then the third one by this time I'm
so burned out I'll say yes to anything
because I just want to go home and watch
football spend time with the kids and
relax I don't have any time to be around
these dealer guys they're annoying
they're pushing me away too much
hypothetically that's what a lot of
people say so time third one money why
do you save money these online auto
brokers have corporate fleet licenses
which means they get a discount on the
cars because they buy a certain amount
of
of cars every year so they get a
discount view and I don't get because of
that pool of discount that they get you
get to participate in it so they'll call
the dealership and they'll say my
customers willing to buy this car for
this price and the payment needs to be
$1200 they'll pretty much negotiate and
the dealership will say now we're not
going to hit it because they contact so
many different dealerships somebody says
yes and because they mutator quota they
haven't sold anything they're sitting on
some cars that they got to get rid of
and you get the discount for that
because the broker the consultant does
the selling for you now you you simply
tell the consultant price point what
you're looking for
he makes the phone call look some of you
may have already said in comment it
belongs to Pat you shouldn't go deal
with an online auto broker there are
apps to buy cars let me explain to you
why I'm not a fan of apps when it comes
onto buying cars here's why as a
financial advisor I can use each trade
and go buy stocks and then lose money
because I'm not the expert or I can use
an expert that business for living and
they counsel me on what to look for what
not to look out for because that's what
they do 24/7 you see when you deal with
an online auto broker they know which
cars are running discounts which cars
are not I'll give you an idea I called
one of my guys named Barret here's what
he said we were about to buy an e 350 he
says Patrick mercedes-benz has a
reputation of changing the e-class every
eight years
it's you're seven you're gonna buy it a
year from that's gonna look like an old
Mercedes as if it wasn't a three I don't
recommend you buying it I said water
makes a lot of sense now adjust and look
at 750 because 750 just came out and
they're gonna be on the marketplace and
this cost us this much that one's is
this much and then he gave me a couple
other options but that advice I'm not
gonna get from the app that advice I'm
gonna get from somebody on Deal mode as
a consultant and then they tell me just
so you know right now Lexus is running
specials you know BMW is not Mercedes is
not or they'll say things like Nissan
had some issues with this car they had a
big thing that just happened with them I
wouldn't buy their car right now or
these guys are running specials on you
know financing for least this one with
your credit I can use this guy with this
do you have access to that but they're
gonna know all the specials on different
kind of cars that's taking place so in
essence they're playing the role of an
adviser to you so then once you speak to
them and they tell you all the specials
narrow down to three cars then go to the
dealership as
showroom because that's exactly what
they are nowadays and by the way even
the dealership owners know dealerships
are showrooms they make more sales up
online than they do at their leadership
all the dealership people know about oh
right now you're going to the showroom
you look at the cars you say well this
is one this is one this is one 25
minutes 30 minutes you go to three
different dealerships okay
great I like this one you call the guy
back he makes a sale for you they get
your financing they deliver it to you
keys sign done so listen if you're
looking to buy a car under $150,000
maybe a 750li or even a Geo Metro call
Barrett he can help you out with that
now on the other hand if you're looking
to buy an exotic maybe a Rolls Royce
Ferrari Lambo Porsche Bentley called
Danny his expertise purely when it comes
on to exotic cars I've left both of
their phone numbers in the description
section
if you're wondering right now st. Pat
should I buy should I lease what should
I do with these cars I don't know what
to do how do I handle my money I made a
video for you titled 20 rules of money
that's got a few million views go watch
a video next